foreign
okay hello everyone we are doing a
design review about the compiler and
Christopher is sharing something here
what are we looking at right so the main
thing we're looking at is stuff with
compiled components which is basically a
thing for having a compiler-based
packlets and also just generally being
able to it's basically the package
system for the compiler and it also lets
you do these sort of packlets whose
implementations are sort of uh uh you
know done in the compiler but there's
also this other thing that's I think a
much quicker topic that's this down
values function thing
um that I think we should probably talk
about first
um so yeah so so basically uh
right let me see if I can introduce this
so basically uh the idea is we have this
thing called kernel function which
basically lets you you know in the
middle of your compiled code you can
write kernel function and this basically
tells it this is a function whose
definition you know who where the
implementation of the function is just
it's going to call the evaluator right
and this is sort of the syntax for it
you sort of say uh you give it a type
and then you apply it and there it goes
so the proposal and there are a few
different parts of this but the first
part to mention is is to have uh this
thing called down values function where
it's it's like kernel function
um except uh I'm not sure why it's not
oh yeah it's just syntax highlighting
being strange yeah it's the same as
kernel function except instead of
actually calling the evaluator it will
at compile time read the down values for
this and compile to run [ __ ] them in and
and compile them nice right so so the
example is you know here I've got this
thing I can compile it
it's compiling I can run it there it
goes I can do the same with the kernel
function and it'll give the same result
but just to prove that it works I'm
going to modify the function and you see
the compiled one it doesn't know about
the modification but the kernel function
does
right because this was compiled before I
modified it it seems nice
right and so good well okay so so I'm
probably going to talk about the name at
some point but right so this is this is
a pretty uncontroversial thing the more
complicated part but this is the reason
this is initially being introduced was
um
basically how you declare how you write
function declarations whose
implementations come from down values
So currently let me ask you a different
question first that's down values what
about sub values and things like that
I mean if you had something that you I I
don't think they're impossible but they
require like you know thought and work
so that's a different function so we
would have it would be something
different yes the point is that this sub
values are not actually functions right
sub values are like sub values objects
they're objects you know which sub
values can be can be done maybe
Christopher I mean another way of
thinking they they are functions but
they just have some of their arguments
in a funny place that's that's another
way of thinking about them so right but
anyway the basic point is this function
is specifically intended for down values
and if we want to do any other kind of
values it's going to be a different
function in the same family right I
think if we had if we had other kinds of
values then it would probably need
slightly different syntax so that would
yeah
um
right so so the reason though why this
is sort of important and not just sort
of a nice little feature is is basically
how you how you Define function
declarations you get their definitions
from down values so right now we have
this is the documented Syntax for doing
that so essentially you have a function
declaration you say you know call it Foo
and then you say typed and then instead
of writing a pure function you just
write a symbol right and then that will
get the down values from that symbol so
the proposal I don't even understand I
don't understand function declaration is
as a sub value has test funk
what does we do no no so the outside
doing that signs with the typed so let
me show you what this what this
oh my keyboard has suddenly stopped
working oh no it's back okay that's
scary
um yeah so so normally this is what you
write
you know
whatever
right so normally what you do is you
write here's a function name here's the
type signature and then here's the
function to compile right
to apply the type signature to the
function it's it's a it's an operator
form you can also write this
I see I see okay right right fine so
yeah it's just it's just a convention I
usually use the operator form
it's not a bad convention I think we no
it's fine I just wasn't used to it
you're good yeah so is there in any
cases that the point is here is that
this is what we do right now is you just
give it the symbol and it says okay if
you give me a symbol as the
implementation I'm going to assume that
that symbol is you know a down values
thing the proposal is to switch it
so so because there's actually another
usage of this syntax I think would be
much make a lot more sense so that
instead the way you do this is you use
down values function so you basically
say function declaration and then the
implementation of the function instead
of giving a pure function you'd say down
values function of test Funk or whatever
okay but that typed wrapper around the
down values function is exactly the same
thing that you would have used in the
usage above right yes yes
okay so the guess you here is whether
that wrapped down values function
is so normally function declaration is
given a pure function
it's given a typed pure function what's
the who I don't understand why is there
both a foo
and say download is a test Funk what is
the food doing the foo is the name of
the function we're declaring so see
here's the actual program we're
compiling and it's calling Foo
right so you don't have to do with down
values of test Funk then
sorry that's where the implementation of
the Foo function Comes
This is the name of the thing this is
the type of the thing and this is the
implementation of the thing right right
so the point is just whether the
implementation spec is a symbol or down
values function of a symbol
but in a sense you're you're it's like a
a module defining a function here I mean
you're temporarily defining the function
Foo equals
essentially test Funk with various types
specified
uh well uh kind of I mean but this is
this is just I mean this is just a
normal syntax or function Explorations
like the fact that it's local and so on
doesn't really matter here but yeah
um
so it's just a function declaration that
says this function named whatever
in the compiler environment will have an
implementation that is this thing that's
specified
right so so really the only change here
so okay the basic point is here's this
schematic of a function declaration
we've got the the name of the function
that we're declaring we've got the type
of the of the function we're declaring
and we have the implementation of the
function right so the question is is
that you know the name spec is staying
the same the type is staying the same
the only question is how the
implementations what do you want
something to be when it's just a pure
symbol though right so that's that's
this next section
um so basically the idea is
um let me see where's the clearest
example okay well let's just look at
this one basically the idea is if it's
just a pure symbol it'll assume that the
implementation is just another function
in the compiler environment as opposed
to being you know a function in the the
symbol table it can know whether I mean
I see it it will only look for things in
the compiler environment you really
don't want it to say you know
in that compiler environment
they're just symbols so I mean it's just
if you write this in a package
uses contexts and whatever okay but so
it doesn't have it it's not a scoping
construct
no no not at all
okay
so there's some globally hanging out
there even though they're ultimately
only used in the innards of the compiler
you know that's and in fact that's kind
of what we're doing with the you know
the pack that thing
but
they're just symbols
so so to justify this though because the
reason why this syntax is is very nice
is because it means that there's a whole
sort of consistency thing where
right so suppose okay so here I'm gonna
declare a function in the compiler
environment right so here now I've got
some function to compile environment
called my function the point is I want
to write this right so normally what you
have to do is you have to write this you
have to say here's a pure function
here's the input you know here I'm
applying the function in the compiler
environment to the input and there you
go but the point is is that what you'd
like to be able to do is just say
function compile and then just say you
know here's the name of the function in
the compiler environment go get me a
compiled code function
it's very nice to do that what
Christopher is saying it's very awkward
um right so hold on hold on so this is
the thing already declared
in that compiler environment the
Declaration doesn't in fact do
compilation it just says what the yeah
okay so with this thing here where
you're declaring it to be a down values
function
but now couldn't you also say function
compile of down values function of blah
uh you mean like like this
yeah I mean with although you might need
the typed
um I think that would make some sense I
I'm not sure no that doesn't work
okay it gives an absurd error but yeah
um I'll make a new notebook to put that
in but but but yeah so I think that that
could work
okay but I mean the points here it
doesn't even matter it doesn't matter
this is a down values function this
could be anything the point is just that
you can compile the function by name and
the reason why that's really useful you
know you'll see with the compiled
component stuff which is why I wanted to
talk about this first but you know
there's this idea of a function that
that you know isn't implemented but but
one day we you know would be very nice
which is you know has various tentative
names but the idea is basically this is
the function for compiling something and
putting the results in down code yep
right so you know this would this is the
most obvious base syntax like most
verbose syntaxes here's where you I want
you to put the function and here's the
implementation of it so this would
install this it would compile this and
install it into my function the symbol
of my function but then the point is
what you want to be able to write is
stuff like this and stuff like this
where you basically just say take the
thing in the compiler and compile it and
put in the top level show the the um uh
the syntax of install the old 35 year
old install phone function
it's horrifyingly simple it's a file I
mean well it is because it uses the
intermediate the template stuff yeah
okay
well the template stuff is just how the
thing's built
I mean you you could write a raw thing
okay so this is a binary this is
installing a binary
foreign
actually does what you're wanting to do
here that is it inserts something into
the down values no it doesn't it makes
down values knock down code
no I understand that but it's it inserts
something
if you say install of ad2 it will
actually
assign values to add two of I underscore
integer J underscore integer and so on
right
yes that's exactly what happens whoops
which is actually pretty nice
this is probably something about context
in stock notebooks
this and and yes well this is a bug
so Aubrey this is for you please
understand I'll report it
weird quotes around it
very strange okay
right
well in any case the the nice thing
about this is it you'll see later I have
an example with a compiled component
where it uses syntax a lot like this and
where it just makes things extremely
simple
um well hold on let's talk about the
this function here
um
uh
Okay so
how does this what what's another thing
that's like this I mean we've got
this is essentially an assignment this
is a thing that is meta programming you
know modifying assignments basically
set delayed is set delayed is a bit like
this
right well so here's the thing so the
reason why you know this is in blue
because it isn't implemented because
it's not for 13.2 and the reason for
that is because there's a whole bunch of
complexity around basically the fact
that right now we don't let people
Define down code for stuff and so if we
do there's some stuff I mean for example
how do you clear it
um and where can you find out about its
existence you know like for example
presumably down value I mean
and install that's what link patterns
was for to figure out what the heck had
happened right well maybe install maybe
then that's actually a reasonable I mean
it's a little Antiquated but it might be
a reasonable thing to to look at to you
know yeah but because I mean one of the
issues is right so one of the options
was maybe it should make a fake entry in
the down values table that's sort of uh
uh makes it look as though it has a down
value I think that's what compiled code
functions that's what exactly
they can't actually have that in the
because the down values will override
the down code
um
is it has a a thing that that um uh has
a thing called call function or
something and it puts into the down
values
a a trivial pattern match whose right
hand side is core function or something
right okay I mean so it's so it's still
going through the pattern matcher which
is not good but it's um
uh but that's how it does it
so having
you know
a faux entry in the down value seems
right to me because then if you clear
the thing it'll clear everything
including that faux entry
yeah you might want to go to restore I
mean there's a little bit more but yes
yes I think that's
all not crazy so
well I mean there's there's some down
values meta programming that we don't
really support right now that involves
you know manipulating reordering Etc et
cetera et cetera down values
um
but we do support that if you actually
write to to down values of food yeah
absolutely yeah you can do that yeah
okay all right well I think this is not
this is not the time to to go into this
thing fine so let's keep going yeah
is a thing but it's incompatible so
sorry function is what
so I think the The Proposal is to
support down values function in 13.2
Christmas yeah yeah yeah but the the
only the reason we bring it up is
because uh there's this thing that
changes you know changes the current
syntax right now a huge number of people
are going to be hanging out fine yes
that's what I think too that's what we
say yeah yeah
I mean I think you know you might try
and put in a bridge message that says
something that is not completely crazy
in the case where it has a symbol there
that it can't find which is the which is
what's going to happen
yeah yeah that can make sense
um okay right okay so compiled
components
so basically compiled components are
it's essentially the packet a compiled
component is a package for the compiler
um
and right that that's all it is so let
me just let me just go down this I have
a sort of demo here so okay the first
thing you're going to do is just
basically append to a component and here
the component doesn't exist yet so I'm
just appending to it to to create it so
if I append to it we have this compiled
component object here it is you know I
can also get a little confusing to
create it at first by doing it because
obviously usually a pen two can't do
that
I mean in other words there isn't a
create compiled component function right
well the issue is that if there were a
create compiled component and if you had
to call it it would mean you have to do
really weird things in your package of
packages which is one of the problems of
the old component system so in
particular
um Let Me by the way packages how come
how come Conor isn't here
well I he could be but also this doesn't
actually involve really much interaction
with the you know it uses like the
packlet system for example but it
doesn't really require any integration
from that side right
Todd's here I mean it's a packler right
yes all right all right okay so so the
reason so for example this is this is a
pack that I was going to show later this
is sort of like a grand use of this
stuff that works very nicely so you see
here this is pretty typical you know I
have the base file and then I have
several sub-files where the actual
component append to is is happening
right
so if so you see in this file operations
dot m files instead of dot WL files but
please continue yeah well so so the the
issue is that see you know that file
gets run when you run needs here so if
you needed to create the compiled
component you have to do it here
which is just
just so bad I mean you're also confusing
because the file
ex okay explain what's happening inside
the GEOS core base
wait a minute geoscore base has has an
append to it is that right yes
and
why couldn't it have the create compiled
component in it well I suppose bass
could but then that would be in the base
is assuming that it's the first thing to
run yeah because if you reordered these
it would break
to really think about what order what we
have here it doesn't matter what order
anything's loaded you see it's just
definitions it's very convenient well I
don't like the name than a pen too I
mean maybe I you know couldn't it just
be ad compiled components or something
well an earlier name was register
compiled component
um
but
yeah yeah so the point is it's not
really what it's doing is it's throwing
more things in the bucket that's called
my component right correct
and there might be zero things in that
bucket initially
well it might not in the design it might
not even exist
right to one analogous thing by the way
is compiler and environment to pen two
but you do have to call create compiler
environments well there always is one
there's always one so yeah I mean you
can call it with one argument but but
you know that just defaults to Dollar
the point is this will never create a
compiler environment yeah which is why I
don't think the other one should be
called a pen two I think it should be
um
well one one thing that maybe would
change a little bit is is if you run
this on some new component that doesn't
exist and this is actually a topic that
we're going to talk about later right
now this returns a failure but this
could return basically an empty
component
right and so what that would mean is
that you know it's sort of like all
components exist they're just all empty
until you append to them
that would by the way be fairly
consistent with how packlets work
because packlets if you just do
something like that
oh uh oh maybe not I thought there was
something where where it returned an
empty packlet object but I guess not oh
no it's like this it returns an empty
packet of object
okay so the issue here is
you are
you've got a bucket it might not have
anything in it this might be the first
mention of the bucket
I don't know somehow I I but it's
probably the wrong name compiled
component Edition
I don't know why that's the right name
that might help him
it sounds too noun-like
you know
um
I mean we could say something like
declare
which is sort of a pun because it's like
you're declaring the component but
you're also declaring that this thing is
part of the component that's not crazy
copy in one in 33 and
[Music]
oh we have the old component system
there's something called that but that's
okay yeah we could get that's that's not
a problem with Christopher I don't think
yeah yeah
um I mean it could be declare compiled
component as well
put a payload in this
that's not quite nice I mean I think
that's
I think declare compiled component is
the
yeah okay I think that that sounds good
so what if that's consistent with the
other declares that you have
well I don't think there are any there
are a bunch of declarations there are no
other declarations
is that consistent with the other names
do you have other names that have
compiled components first I mean I don't
really don't like the verb first uh
style of naming declare
yeah well I haven't I think it was build
compiled component and load compiled
component but they could be compiled
component uh build no I don't think they
should be I think that these are cases
where like create comes first I think
there are things Todd where I agree with
you that it goes you know noun verb but
I don't think these are examples of that
but it's it's subtle and I agree it
could go either way but I think I think
this is slightly better
it's not easier for searching if they're
consistent
well
I I think it's better to do it this way
around especially if you've got okay
we'll see the other functions that you
have around compiled components but by
the way on that point about searching I
feel like at some point we should get I
mean a lot of you know Ides and text
editors and things they won't just
search from the beginning you know if
you type compiled computers I know I
know I know we've been supposed to have
that forever and ever it's been
postponed multiple times it might make
it to thirteen two right that's an
argument to uh to not
choose function names but yeah right
but but okay so so basically okay you
pen to it or okay if you declare to it
um then now you've got this component
one thing this is kind of an
implementation detail but the full form
of it is just that so this is just a
reference to a component that is out
there it is not you know and the reason
for this is because otherwise you know
if this actually had the association in
it then you know you you append to it
here and then you have this older
version of it sitting somewhere else
that doesn't have that declaration in it
okay but when you save it in a file what
happens
so the way you say so I think if you if
you just tried to save it in like an MX
file nothing good would happen but there
is a way of serializing it
um
but that is actually a reasonable thing
to think about is how would you
how do you save it with a greater than
greater than put into a file
um well I mean if you just did it like
that it wouldn't work what happens if
you reactivate the notebook and things
it wouldn't work you'd have to you'd
have to run these again I guess one
thing it could do I mean
if if it came from a pack load of course
it would work
sure I knew where the packlet was
yeah so it's a one one option is it
could have although I'm a little
skeptical of this it could have sort of
a cache of the association in its second
argument you know it wouldn't it would
never display it and you'd still be able
to create them like this but the actual
full form of this would have
you know the implementation there
now the only problem with this is that
first of all it might cause some issues
the same cue but I don't think people
doing the same QR components is very
common the other thing would just be
that uh
you would have out-of-date versions
running around
you would have something or maybe in my
notebook I have a few of these little
compiled component things and uh you
know one of them I choose to rehydrate
um and and you know but oh but it's
different from all the other ones but so
look it's a bit like the symbol table
you know in
you don't by default save the symbol
table this is another indirectly
referenced name correcting correct
which is an argument to just have it be
like the symbol table and not get
serialized directly and require that you
do the equivalent of a save I mean the
put won't work but save could
could save be made to work with this
I think you should the same yeah that's
saved I'm not even trying to ever use
this image I've used dump save I've
never used normal stage
well I mean it saves symbol values
it does the thing that get doesn't do I
mean get I'm sorry put put simply takes
an expression and puts it somewhere
hey hold on I'll be back in just a
second keep keep going I'll be back
[Music]
okay
um but
I don't really know
I don't think it's very serializable
it's like a link object or
well no the components I think are
totally serializable I mean they're
they're just I mean like
you you you don't that's fine it doesn't
it doesn't even know it doesn't need to
know that it came from a packlet at all
I mean it's just it's just a list of
declarations and things to compile
I I think if it came from a packlet and
then you serialize some different
version of it you would be all sorts of
confusions will happen
that's true like if basically you wrote
this components you're expecting it to
come from a packlet but then you uh you
also have a serialized version of in
your notebook and those two versions are
competing that could lead to weird
things
well but it can't because I mean we
talked about how there isn't any dollar
current packlet thing like there's no
way of knowing what packlet you're
running in
[Music]
hello
what do you mean there's no what does it
mean to run in a packlet
it doesn't really mean much I think
that's sort of the problem so I mean the
point being that if you have say uh say
you know the packlet says in its
extensions you know oh I I have this
context I Define this context
um then the point is you know well
there's some dot WL file that defines
that context and you know the question
is in that WL file can you ask hey what
packlet am I associated with but but
there isn't I'm not sure there's really
a well-defined way of saying what that
associated with is
I mean we have this dollar input thing
um input file name or something isn't it
yeah I mean you can capture your
location the location of the WL file at
the time it's radiant and save that
yourself but if you're just running some
function to find in their WL file
there's no way to say where did I come
from you know
there's no you know dollar file that
defined this function thing in this in
the language
but I don't understand because we
certainly have
when you're reading when you're pausing
from a file you certainly can get dollar
input gives you the name of the file
isn't it
yeah
and you can capture that lots of people
do they'll Define some Global variable
within their package that captures the
location at the time it's red and then
they can sort of manually use that but
if if you don't do that
then there's no way just to sort of ask
what what Hackler or what input file did
this function definition come from while
it's running unless that's manually
saved
I mean we probably could capture that
how would we do that I'm not even sure
though what what it because I mean the
connection between a packlet and the WL
file that that we consider the
implementation of the packlet is pretty
tenuous and the packet itself is just a
pack of info file
which says something like you know
uh you know oh I I I I I extend this uh
you know this context and then when you
run needs
like I don't know I I think it's it's
pretty hard to know which uh
the connection between the actual
implementation file and the packlet info
is pretty tenuous good enough okay
anyway let's keep going on this main
review
right well okay so so the basic point
though is that this is a reference it
doesn't actually contain the information
it's just a reference so that way you
know you can't have two versions of them
sitting around that are different
um right right but but okay so so then
you know you can you can accomplish that
relate entity store is another thing
that works like that
you mean uh just the entity store header
dollar entity stores or whatever it's
called well I mean not enter this store
has you know it is an indirect thing
where you have the name of an entity
type
and then
it isn't the entity type I don't think
let's see the entity store maybe does
have a content in it but when you're
actually dealing with an entity the
serialization is always again
non-trivial because you can have an
entity of type Foo
oh sure I mean it's just basically that
the entity object itself you know
doesn't doesn't contain any of the you
know it refers to this this entity store
right yep
yeah and if you serialize this and
deserialize it it'll just be like
confused yep
yeah that that is analogous
okay but but okay so so here you know we
you know put some declarations into it
you see now it says I have two
declarations
so let me
I'll show in a second how you use these
declarations the first there are some
other fields in the in you know in these
things
so the first one is well well right the
first one is Library functions
so here basically the syntax said if you
want to add anything other than
declarations you do that with this
syntax so you say the component then you
say what you know to what field you'd
like to declare something because again
we're imagining this says declare
compiled component and then you give it
you know the payload
um so essentially what this is saying is
when we build the component which we'll
do later this is just specifying
something that we want to be included in
the the library that gets built this is
basically just saying in that Library
you should have these functions defined
where this is following the same syntax
as function compile export Library
that last part is but I don't understand
that you had a thing previously where
you said declare compile component and
then could you scroll up because you you
were declaring it with literal code
there
yeah
right so that's declaring a this is
equivalent to writing this
if I could type
um and what this is doing is it's just
appending to the to the Declarations of
this component right this is this is so
close the point is a component is just
this basically inert container and it
contains information that can be used
both if you want to if you want to
basically compile something that uses
this functionality you can refer to this
component it could use all those
declarations from this component the
other thing that it can be used for is
that you can build the component and
then you get this this built component
library and that component Library can
do all sorts of fancy things those are
the two main things this does
don't you have a library function
wrapper that represents a library
function declaration and why do you
bother to have that second argument of
compiled component
the library function wrapper is is a
totally different thing
okay the Declaration oh yeah sorry it's
a call right
right so this is basically saying so
like I mean if nothing else if I just
say uh
component
why is my autocomplete is being very
strange right now
um
oh I haven't run this yet okay so if I
say this at all this might help so this
is this is everything that's in the
component this is what defines the
component so you see it's just it's just
this inert thing there's a list of
declarations here's an association of
Library functions and here's two things
that we haven't seen yet
um
and so basically when when we call build
compiled component which I do lower down
it's just all this is saying is that one
of the things is to include
uh you know basically all builds
compiled component does is it builds
this this library and this is just
saying by the way include these
functions in the library that way when I
call load compiled component I have
access to compiled versions of these
functions
I'll basically get back a version of
this Association
where where these are compiled code
functions why is that person called
declaration it's not function
declarations
because they can also be types they can
also be compile expression declarations
they can do whatever you want yeah any
compiler declaration
um
right okay so let me just let me just
keep going here it's okay so we have
some Library functions
um this other one is installed functions
this is analogous to that function
compile install thing that doesn't exist
yet
right but but it follows the exact same
syntax which is sort of the the reason I
brought it up so here I'm writing you
know here's the symbol name here's the
definition another thing that you can
write though is you can just write you
know
boo where Foo is something that was
declared in the Declaration section
um and and that will also work although
here I don't think what is an installed
function that's something that's going
to be put in the down values
in the down code yes down code yeah and
I I have an example that I'll show you
this is actually kind of the main
feature that lets you do
nice stuff
um okay but it's sort of hard to explain
till we get to we get to the building
part
um the last thing worth mentioning
quickly is there these so-called
prologues which are basically just
functions that get evaluated at build
time uh at load time and at declaration
time basically so the the usage of this
is for loading libraries so if I have
some functions that I'm defining that
rely on some libraries or or where you
know when I load the build of the
component I also need to load you know
open SSL or something like that this is
where you do that
um okay but it also it also presumably
will give you a
um a progress dialogue if the load time
is going to be larger and stuff like
that the load time is is Trivial the
load time the build time can be long but
the load time is never more than you
know
half a second even if it was some weird
machine learning thing that was Giant
yeah like it usually the load time is
very quick because it's just loading a
dynamic Library
it's not compiling anything
I don't even know what loading a dynamic
Library means I mean does it map it into
some address space or something that
doesn't even copy any bits
well Tom probably knows more about what
basically I think it has to do it has to
do a little bit of work but it but
modern OS is it's terribly lazy so it
has to resolve dependencies it can fail
um I love the way that the the fact that
it's totally lazy means it's terribly
fast but anyway never mind yes yes well
you you you yes correct
um I mean it does as little work as
possible you know basically okay all
right onward
just something real quick in that
compiled component of pen two why you
have prologues comma and then some
prologues they have installed functions
comma why isn't that install function's
Arrow prologues Arrow right and then you
can have a whole bunch in one in one
yeah well so one thing I was thinking
about would be supporting some
Association syntax because if nothing
else that means you could take the
serialized version of feeding it here
the reason why I don't want to just do
an arrow here all the time is if nothing
else because there are things like
installed functions Library functions
where if you give only one of them it's
a rule right so here I'm giving a whole
association of them here I'm giving only
a single one and so it makes sense for
this just to be a rule and so if you
allowed for uh their their weird
precedence I mean this just looks really
weird to write but if you made it if you
made an association so Library functions
Arrow Association
thank you
and then you can have as many of these
things piled into one a pen two as you
want
different types of components
right you could also do the different
types of components you could also just
support something like
you know you could support the the
I guess there would be a little bit
inconsistent but you could support that
and then also just support
uh
this
I agree with Todd that I think it'd be
better to have these Arrow things and I
think that this is not you know
these things will be as often written by
machines as by people
and the less obscure this thing is when
you see it
the better
I mean I think
the one thing about the pure rule form
is it they kind of look like options
right you know the last argument to a
function if it were not just you know
but you could group them in a list or an
association or you could just ignore the
fact that they look like options it just
uses straight rule well I'm worried that
you may need options
right and if we need options later right
then we would have a problem
so another thing to mention quickly but
but I'm not sure this really affects it
much let me show you a real example
because you often end up with
uh
right you often end up with long you
know the inside of here is something big
so here's an example where I'm appending
declarations to geoslink this is taking
advantage of the fact that the second
argument defaults to declarations but
basically you know I'm giving it this
list but you can see you know this is a
long block of of stuff
which sometimes I think can be awkward
if it's on the right hand side of a rule
Maybe
I mean you just put the rule up there
and then arrow and then it hangs then
all the rest of it is nested
doesn't seem that terrible
would it still defaults to declarations
though if you just give it a list or a
single item
songs that isn't ambiguous I think it
should you know why not
trying to think if there are any cases I
guess there are no there are no
declarations that take the form of just
a rule so I think it is unambiguous
yeah okay well I can I can imagine
pretty nice by the way that the way that
whole declaration thing you know it's
incredibly nice
yeah sorry I'm going to show this this
example of the the big example at the
end so this is spoilers okay
um but but yeah okay this is a fine that
can that can use that could use rules I
think that's that's fine but now also
would it support
this I'm not sure how common this is
I don't think it needs to it's not so
terrible to put that in an association
yeah I mean if you write like this I
think it looks much better to put an
association because it does damage just
sitting there
all right let's keep going I think
probably the association I would I would
Define the most encrusted form first
and
you know trust that what's that
yes it needs to be smooth okay keep
going right can I just jump in one more
thing because did we decide to declare
compile component was the replacement
for a pen two the thing about declare
compile components it sounds like it's
this this just updates an existing
compiler component right it really isn't
kind of an add to thing it it looks like
a overwrite kind of a replace kind of
operation doesn't it declare compile
component there's nothing in that name
that suggests it's adding to something
well maybe compiled component declare
might be mildly better in that sense I
mean it's like I like that better for
other reasons but I'm not sure if it
changes the
my thinking on the I think it does
slightly I mean
well because declare compiled component
it's very clear that the thing you're
declaring is the compiled component as
opposed to compiling component declare
where it's a bit of a pun about whether
you're declaring the component or
whether you're declaring things that are
associated with the component
yeah I suppose but
I don't know
I prefer the verb now
because of the initial
yeah
um
it's very hard to have something which
both represents you know if there was
nothing there started and add to what's
there
foreign
things are kind of are suggested of that
where you're just sort of adding into
some state
um
which is why register compiled component
was another possibility yeah right yeah
it was it was in the original thing it
was but uh
what do we use register for elsewhere I
mean
we have register for entity stores and
things like that
we have register for packlet sites
does it mean the same thing
yeah it means add to a list of known
packlet sites
now I know but
yeah it's it's right this is more like
adding to this compiled component it's
not registering a compile component in
some right global data
um okay we're gonna run out of time so
let's keep going okay let me let me go
to the examples but
um
right okay so uh let me skip down here
okay so the first thing is how you use
components other compiled programs so we
have this compiled component one of the
things it defined was this my funk thing
so you know if I compile this my phone
because it's defined but you can use
compiled component as effectively a
declaration so this is the slot where
you put things like function declaration
type declaration whatever you can also
just use this and it effectively you
know and you could put it in a list
include other declarations too but this
effectively is just a big ball of
declarations when you use it in a case
like this so here you know my funk is
defined
um similarly if you wanted to include
this in a compiled component then or
sorry sorry in a compiler environment
you would also just run compiler
environment to pen two and just like any
other declaration you can throw this in
and it will you know put it into the
Declaration
um
so is the content of a compiled
component or is declarations or can it
be other things it has other things too
but declarations are the only thing
that's relevant for doing confirmation I
see
the other things are relevant for sort
of like interaction with the top level
yeah with the library
okay
so yeah so basically just it behaves
like a declaration in all these contexts
okay so the libraries that were the big
the big thing okay so there are
basically two functions
um build component compiler component
and load compiled component so if I call
build it will go off and it will compile
it ignore this this message just because
I'm using some internal uh version of
the packlet
um you see it ran the prologues that
might have you know uh loaded the
libraries and so on and it returned the
success object
and it tells me you know where it was
built and so on by default it builds
into like that place in the user base
directory where create Library dumps
things so it kind of just gets dumped in
this Central area that find library can
find but which is sort of uh you know
yeah like a scratch space area
um
and now to load it so there's there's
there's you guys so that presumably you
have an option that puts in a different
place is it a like yeah it's a second
argument and yeah a little bit below in
fact the the most useful thing is you
can say you can give it a packlet object
in the second argument and it will put
it into the packlet in the correct
directory and so on
um but but okay so so the the thing that
this does though
um so you can load it explicitly by
calling load compiled component but I'm
going to show a different way of loading
it first which is that when you call uh
you know declare compiled component and
you declare some installed function
when you do the Declaration it actually
sets uh a down value for that symbol so
above we ran uh somewhere we said yeah
installed function we added in you know
this installed Funk one and when we ran
this line it added a down value for uh
for installed Funk one that that looks
like this and I mean actually this could
probably be a bit cleaner but basically
this is just loads the compiled
component and then tries to you know
call the the the compiled version of
this so this is this is very analogous
now packlet auto loading Works where you
know the symbol will have some sort of
uh definition that's kind of a
placeholder but once you use it then it
will actually do loading
and so if I then run this you see it it
ran the you know it loaded the thing and
now it's defined and now when I run this
again this is just calling the down code
definition of this symbol why is that
thing blue
um
I'm not so it seems to be inconsistent
about whether it's blue or not it's blue
because there are no down values for it
because it just has down code
um it seems when I do this when this is
defined in a packlet so it's in some
context as opposed to Global it doesn't
turn blue
and I don't really know why yeah it's
something to do with the syntax coloring
but I'm sure that could be fixed
okay
yeah but the point is this is just a
down code function now
um
right and so alternatively that could
have been loaded by calling load
compiled component which does the same
thing but which also returns other stuff
so for example it Returns the library
functions which includes all those
Library functions that you asked to be
compiled so you know that way you can
ask for things to be compiled and you
can access them later through this and
uh you know it includes whatever it
happened to install and stuff like that
um
one other nice features if the if the
component that you have in memory gets
out of alignment with the component that
it loads it can it can let you know
um which is sort of a nice
feature
um
okay
so let me let me maybe show a practical
example because it makes it clear what's
going on
um
so actually you know what I'm going to
show the fancy packlet because now show
the nice one
so yeah yeah so okay so here's here's uh
this is a fresh kernel this is a
different kernel from this one so this
um
uh right so so here actually let me make
sure it's a fresh kernel so I have this
pack of geoslink it defines a uh uh
compiled component called geoslink
um
and uh
for some reason this notebook is hanging
like it's it's just
oh
one hour back okay there we go so now
I've previously
it's very
strange okay well previously I I built
this
it's not even actually not responding
it's responding just fine so I don't
know why it keeps thinking it's not
responding
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna reopen this
because it's just being
broken
um
I mean this is a very streamlined way to
get significant functionality from
that's built with a compiler yeah so so
okay so basically what I'm going to do
is I have this packlet it's already been
built I I pack the directory load it and
I run needs so that's that's for a
normal packlet that's all you run and
now in order to do it I don't have to
run any kind of load the pack or
anything like that I'm just going to
call GEOS initialize
which is a you know just a this is a
GEOS function this isn't a function that
I Define this is an installed function
that calls some C code whatever and the
point is is that GEOS initialize you
know when I run it it will automatically
load the library and now all these
functions are you know defined and I can
you know do whatever I want
and the only reason just just to be
clear because I I just realized this
this might be misleading just initialize
is not something that like loads a
component this is just a GEOS has a
function that needs to be run yeah
um so basically you could have put in
your some kind of prologue if you wanted
it to be auto run whenever any other
function from the GEOS library is run or
is that not true
um no you couldn't put it in prologue
maybe we I mean I actually we had
discussion of maybe having a thing
called epilogue which might be able to
do something like that but I have to
think about it
um seems useful to be able to have
because I think a lot of libraries a lot
of external libraries will have
something that requires initializing
them
so it feels like yeah if you're calling
a function from within the external
Library
like this just boundary thing
right let me just make a random note
about that
but right so so the point though the
main point here though is that from the
perspective of the packlet user it's as
if these things were defined with set
delayed you know there's no visible
anything that that these are you know
involved can we see the source code of
the of the like from GEOS and things
like that it's over there
so so basically declaration
here go ahead this is just a list of
declarations so basically I'm saying you
know measures saying okay pend two I
want you know all these declarations and
so these are things this is just
standard compiler stuff I'm saying I
want GEOS area here's this declaration a
little bit lower I have a function
declaration that defines a function
called geosaria and it's got some
implementation that calls the the
library function
thing
this is an unfortunate thing this is
basically just because we don't have an
exception mechanism in the compiler
right now or at least not a not a
documented one basically because uh
there isn't a top level exception
mechanism to emulate and there's enough
talk about maybe having something like
that from the error handling stuff that
we don't want to invent one come on
so yeah so this is sort of in limbo
right now but but okay so I'm defining
all these you know all these functions
um something like the name dist pointer
is that a c language name inside the
GEOS library or what is that where do
you see dist pointer a little bit higher
up or G1 G2 whatever they are I mean
these are just argument names to the
function
oh I see
oh I see I said okay fine so just
disjoint is the function in GEOS yeah
right so so in a case I declare all
these functions and then I just say
installed functions bang and there's a
big list of names and then when I call
build it just knows you know okay I'm
just going to build all these functions
and you know put them in the library and
then when I load the thing anytime I
refer to one of those symbols it will
load it and it will you know have the
implementation there and everything
this is very very nice but I mean So
within a packlet a typical thing would
be that those symbols will wind up in
some fairly private context that can
then be uh sort of fished out of for
various uses maybe they might be the
exports from the packler they are look
at the packlet info here they probably
are in this package maybe they're I
don't think I mentioned them but they're
really good connections through the
context they're they're exported these
are the exports oh look look in the
geoslink.ab then maybe there
oh yeah sure they're listed here yes
right so I mean these are juices right
these are the exports from the packlet
they're not private this is
you know it
and and going through down code is so
freaking fast you know no I understand
that I'm just saying that in terms of of
what happens when we're writing code I
mean you don't want to spray these
things into the system context or into
the global contest they're not I mean
they're just these are just symbols
there's nothing special about them when
you call you know one of these uh one of
these things here it's just like calling
set delayed it's just a symbol
in whatever context it's naturally in
yeah correct yeah
it's not doing any parser Wizardry or
anything like that
well so I mean the real thing here is
the translation of data structures which
I'm suspect is non-trivial
like right I mean that's what that's
that's the big file that's I've you know
the big file which actually does the
conversion between a GEOS multi-line
string and you know a line expression
does it actually work does all this
stuff actually work yeah totally I have
a great example of this I mean I think
the the eventual use of this particular
package is I think Jose talked about
wanting it for yeah yeah geopolygon
operations but I had an example
um that I was working on just like a
couple days ago where I had like 72 000
census tracts which have like millions
of vertices or something actually not
Millions but it's like it's like a
hundred megabytes of geometry or
something like that and I was doing
things like you know Computing the
region Union of you know 20 000 of them
and it runs in like half a second and
like region Union that takes like hours
so you know but the other important
thing is that I I had operations where
I'm passing these things back and forth
many times and as a test I tried making
serialize and deserialize at each step
right so basically it goes through this
code of turning it into an expression
and turning it back into a GEOS thing at
each step even though there was like a
hundred megabytes of geometry it does
that you know that that back and forth
was negligible like it was like took you
know 0.05 seconds or something like that
doing it like five times so it's
yeah it's it's very very efficient
that's great that's great so I mean look
this is this is now you know this is
becoming a major use case so the
compiler is Library linking
right yeah and then the whole point is
with compiled components it'll actually
be you know there'll be a way of making
a packlet that does the live because the
issue right now is that we don't you
know without compiled components there
isn't a good way if Jose says I want a
library you know I want a way of calling
GEOS with the compiler I can give them a
notebook that has code that you can run
you know but but or I can give him a a
DOT so or dot DUI lib file that you can
call library function load on and get
back a big Association of functions but
this is the only way to be like just
call needs on this and you have a bunch
of symbols
right so you can included in a packlet
and so
in the packet repository and in the
function repository it becomes possible
to just incorporate functions that make
use of external libraries like this
yeah yeah now now there's also some
interesting stuff I mean we haven't
really we haven't really thought much
about this but for something like the
packet repository we could imagine
having some kind of service for
basically we run the build compiled
component right and we can run it on all
platforms and stuff like that
um
but I haven't I I haven't no I'm just
mentioning that but you know we haven't
actually done any work about that so I
don't know how possible it is well I
mean we have a system you know there's a
slightly older version of this component
system that we've been using for several
versions like to create libraries for
the kernel and they integrate really
well with our team City you know that's
that's all being figured out so that
that would be a way
right I I have to disappear in a moment
here but but um uh
so what do we do what what do we do with
this because it's very nice
well I think we get it too yeah right
good good and uh
I mean it looks pretty clear I mean it
looks you know it it's somewhat
complicated but I mean how could it not
be I mean correct given what it's trying
to do I I mean I think the the big thing
internally to the company is I mean I
know we've been looking at various
libraries and people have been spending
ridiculous amounts of time integrating
those libraries it's now kind of this
makes it you know we should be figuring
out what libraries people want to
integrate and making sure that all this
works smoothly
yep
um
and uh I see a question on a live stream
about webassembly and GPU TPU stuff and
so on that's a different direction in
the compiler also being worked on
correct um
the uh all right
looks good okay anything else we need to
cover
I don't think so okay it's very very
nice stuff I mean and this is very
impressive I mean I don't know how long
this GEOS link thing took this looks
like I mean was this fairly
straightforward to do the main part of
just like all this conversion code and
being able to you know call arbitrary
functions took about a day and a half
and then you know and then I I've since
then done little things of just adding
little functions but adding functions is
like trivial like for example the other
day I added these you know prepared
geometry function events just like you
just write the Declaration for the
function in in C and then you know
here's just a trivial thing it's just
converting you know if it returns a zero
that's false right I mean it's it's
pretty simple
um
so I mean the only hard part was running
the conversion code but again that took
like a day so so what kind of
documentation do we have for people to
understand what on Earth to do here
do you mean how to use the compiled
components or how to use for example
of how to take a random library and you
know
uh like this there's a good there's a
there's a
there's a tutorial that I wrote in the
last version that has a simple example
with openssl uh much more extended fancy
example sqlite
um so this is the place to go but of
course this doesn't use compiled
components I think we'd want another
tutorial explaining how beautiful one
similar but yeah yeah
looking very good looking very good yeah
I mean the
um
terrific
yeah by the way Christopher are you in
the there's a meeting later that
is and I think is finishing astronomy
and geography you might you might want
to join that
um uh I have some other meetings later
but I can I can try and join okay all
right sounds good okay see you all soon
thanks a lot okay bye